so on order four covers Table six
milestone for venison Wellington yeah
sure thank you big competition date
going head-to-head against emissions
direction yeah you got no cooking school
today no downstairs no upstairs one
kitchen 20 dinars no excuses what's the
chances I'm optimistic oh yeah nothing
we're gonna do it
elves are they've got a Michelin star we
haven't so saw the underdogs but if we
can do this then they'll be amazing head
chef Simon is pulling out all the stops
with a ballsy dish of roast venison loin
and a haunch of venison and nettle
Wellington so with beetroot fondant
watercress puree and braised lettuce
this could be the dish my career if all
goes well then it could change things
for us drastically how far off time is
six minutes seven six yeah six and six
yeah
Simon's dish requires perfect timing
something you messed up when he fed my
coach diners
[Music]
that's environment I'd rather keep the
customers waiting there for five minutes
in the server beetroot that's not good
proper yeah there's no room for mistakes
all six elements of this dish must be
cooked perfection I for venison up to
the pass now
guys make every plate count
happy service yup go please
but in his haste to get the food out
Simon has made a terrible schoolboy
error how did we get that lettuce I'm
[ __ ] up Joey the point is you've done
that by now get me wrong please urgently
let's go now that's the braised letter
so we've got off the main go it's fine
it's not on there now they haven't
finished it then no enough way through a
go please yeah yeah just apologize
quickly thank you got some fun just
behind this a braised baby gem lettuce a
more experienced chef will recover from
a mistake like this quickly but Simon's
rattled I miss stay off the play as some
pissed off and fist up to myself look I
mean is that he's done yeah
you pull it back come on one more table
let's go yeah Thank You chef
30 seconds Venice little bit first right
coming up on this here yeah [ __ ] jump
light up the source up at this time the
lettuce is on the plate you're not
separate table one pleasure see this
start working up another four yeah yeah
zombies bounce back and he's talking to
James and more importantly they're
together as a team so it's a dynamic duo
I supposed to one up one down
happy that yeah so this very nice the
dishes looked fantastic absolutely
delicious
James yeah Sam keep it going yeah yeah
actually last several yes by the last
table look exactly it takes exactly the
same as a first pleasure Jenny okay good
over you most annoying person nettle
Wellington it looks absolutely
brilliantly smells I know most of it
this is just spectacular attentively
succulent yeah super clean flavors
neatly feeling a definite hold on guys
yeah yeah big deep breath oh that [ __ ]
nice service is over my discerning guess
of tasted both restaurants food I want
to find out what they thought starting
with a milestone let's talk the venison
with the Wellington wonderful
combination of flavors a texture the
taste it really worked for me
Wilfred how was it the person who did
the Wellington I would he is so eager to
win yeah it looks like a cage fighter
there's like it's ready for action yeah
that big way and you can see that in the
dish there was too much going on and
then the one with cherry was a bit more
laid-back yes is the west house that was
my preference and it's because wasn't
trying too hard I prefer the west house
I thought the way they cook venison was
perfect and I absolutely loved the liver
which is something I normally don't eat
and was a real treat I referred the
Wellington wait yeah I thought I was a
fantastic I thought hey she was
brilliant he was really live extremely
difficult issues yes actually a bit like
two beautiful ladies your teacher huh